the ring city there's a lot of stuff to
talk about in this DLC after all it is
the last piece of Dark Souls content
ever so let's try looking at things as
they come to it first up we have the
Drake heat the intro to the DLC our
first area there's not a crazy amount of
story going on here but there is some
interesting war concerning the enemies
and the characters here that is
definitely worth it to check out the
Angels they seem to sprout from pilgrim
if we kill the stone hum tag pilgrim she
says that she'll want to see an angel
and a black angel appears in this area
later on hinting that there's a natural
growth from the pilgrims to the flying
creature these enemies are quite similar
to the pilgrim butterflies that we see
in law 3 there could be some connection
between them of the angels turning to
the butterflies or the butterflies
turning the angels or they're just close
relative the angels also serve is one of
the main defenses and guards at drag
heap before the rain city blocking our
path not necessarily blocking but
definitely impeding our progress the
royalty of Loffler could be
intentionally using them to ward off any
venturers from delving into the ring
city they don't want them moving past
just the Angels the other enemies in
this area
the Merc man the herald Knights etc seem
to be less purposeful at least from a
lower perspective the herald Knights
sought the Dark Soul but were corrupted
and bloated by the devil
they now try to destroy anything that
provokes them the Merc man imbued with
some depth power of a similar goal of
catching any traveler off guard and
delivering dark justice to them
one other note you can meet laughs and
an easy a quants to regain his memory a
couple of times in the drej heat he
seems like an upstanding guy and can
even help us once we reach the end of
the area and arrive at the demon print
I originally wrote a nice paragraph
about the Beast the Lauren slew for this
section but the description of the demon
Prince's soul recently got updated and
with that update the lore change so
here's the new description of the soul
the demons birthed from a common chaos
share almost everything between them
even the pride of their prints the New
York faded flame so that the last demon
standing a rekindle so the demon from
pain and the demon from below are
actually two new demon the last of their
kind they've been together through thick
and thin all their lives ever since they
were born from the chaos flame they've
come across the flame of the original
demon Prince that Laureen slew and when
we take each of them down the last one
remaining uses that flame take on the
power of the demon Prince and plate on
as him demon Prince serves as the final
gatekeeper to the ring city preventing
almost anyone from entering or leaving
the city of thinking after defeating the
prince we get the small and boy banner
which relates to us the basic idea of
the Ring City it reads for the pygmies
who took the Dark Soul the Great Lord
Clinton gifted the ring city an isolated
place at World's End and his beloved
youngest daughter promising her that he
would come for her when the day came
bolts the pygmies and Gwynn's daughter
sylia nor have big roles in the upcoming
event before we leave the arena of this
ball so it has some possibly unnoticed
significant in it are some of the ruins
of Firelink shrine from Dark Souls 1
there's the main bonfire circle in the
area leading to Fromm's hole I don't
think there are any specific law
implications at this moment I'd say it's
just a nice callback but is something
really interesting to take note of one
last thing before we head to the ring
city proper are the facilitators of
transport at the end boy bander calls
them that take you to the city they're
the battling demons we've seen so often
key word here being demon they obviously
don't have nearly the power or presence
of the demon Prince so the old demon
king but they are nevertheless demon
maybe this means of the demon race isn't
completely gone
if even a tiny smidge
remain there's still a bit of hope one
explanation I saw for how they could
live without the chaos flame when all of
the other demons have faded away is that
the gods enslave them made them not
dependent on the chaos flame but gave
them a different source of power so that
they would serve God since we do see
them doing things like transporting
protecting areas the gods want protected
in Dark Souls 1 and Dark Souls 3 the
ring city now on to the main course of
the DLC let's first take a basic look
some of the main elements we'll see
through the next couple of areas to give
us a better background of the ring city
as a whole
and so that explanations about things
are easier because everything's so
interconnected first up we have princess
feeling on the centerpiece of the city
she resides asleep atop the church tower
at the focus of our journey their goal
throughout most of the upcoming sections
is fighting your way to her room
the judicata robe wearing behemoths
summon legions of invincible spirits to
attack you they serve princess who
Leonor and wants to protect her slumber
doing everything in their power to stop
you from getting to her and waking her I
posit that they're led by the main Judah
cater that beam through Decatur agro who
we'll talk about more later the locust
locusts and men are kindred spirits
taking this and effect the forlorn Airy
ndele mutated into something insect like
when near rot
maybe the locusts are the result of men
or something close to them being near
the abyssal swamp
maybe it's corrupting purpose why is the
white-faced locusts were meant to beckon
men to the dark with sermon but most of
them aren't able to think past their own
stump we can hear the locusts mutter
when they attack
but it seemed that the insatiability of
their stomachs prevent them from doing
their full job of preaching however
there are a few non hostile ones
throughout the city that do cryptically
preach to us about the greatness of the
dark and a bit serving their role as
preachers to men luring them to the dark
and so despite his weighty AMA he lived
in fear of a delicate thing little more
than a girl with fiery sided shadows
twist and shrivel but in the abyss there
are shadows not fear not the dark my
friend and let the feast begin lastly we
have the ringed nights here's another
group that's somewhat aligned with the
abyss their armor and weapons were
forged in the abyss and the gods feared
them for this reason so the god branded
them with a seal of fire the dark side
the gods displaying their fear of the
dark and the abyss and acting on that
fear the powerful theme throughout this
you'll see probably throughout all of
Dark Souls keep on the lookout for it as
we continue down the lore of their Incan
City now that we have an understanding
of who will be seen as we progress we
can start talking about the actual story
progression an important note that I
haven't mentioned yet that throughout
this whole DLC for chasing a Sur slave
night Gale from ashes of aerion de this
was said when the dlc was first
announced and it's easy to see he guides
us through drag sheep leaving notes and
pointers he's even available to summon
the demon Prince when we first get to
the Ring City an npc lets us know why
we're there defying the dark soul and
Gale is looking for this - as the
painter back in arendelle needs to paint
a new world and she needs the dark soul
as pigment the whole journey were a step
behind Gale this changes at the very end
of the dlc but before then we have a
boss fight a dragon and quite a few
other pieces of important lore as we
delve deep into the ring city will come
across laughs a few more times he's
searching for a sir
in purging monument to regain his memory
if we complete the show your humanity
riddle find the monument and tell him we
can reach the end of his quest in the
Kris those trick you and reveals is now
remembered identity its patches but he
doesn't actually put you in any danger
when he tricks you and kicks you off a
small clip he leaves behind a nice set
of armor and he actually pushes you in
the direction that you normally would
have had to go once you get to that
location in the crib so it's pretty well
appreciated one does have to wonder how
patches made it all the way to the ring
city and got hollowed at that but that's
the talk for another day the patch a
storyline in this DLC is one that's
pretty peculiar especially his final
dialogue but we'll talk about that
sometime later another NPC that can be
found in the city is Shira a handmaiden
and Knight aphelion or and one who is of
royal blood herself she pleads with you
to slay the dragon meteor that he's been
corrupted by the dark his sworn enemy I
would have you put the dragon dramatic
before the dark consume it in and
evolved I forgot I often like to
gratitude thou who can endure God's name
it seems not even one of the mightiest
beast can avoid the darks potent touch
manure will make your bridge crossings
in the Ring City quite a pain but he can
eventually be beating down to the lower
chasm Fira will let you know that you
need to finish the job the shortcut near
the Gwyn statue revealed the secret of
entrance to my dears lair
a quick aside about that Glynn statue
its Quinn crowning a pygmy we know that
the Ring City was a gift from Gwyn to
the pygmies also possibly a sort of
prison to keep them contained the act
captured in this piece of stone shows
when further placating the pygmy the
vessels of the Dark Soul he like the
other gods feared the power that they
held as the Dark Soul was one of the
four great Lord Souls the source of the
gods power when knew that he had to stay
on the pygmies good side if he didn't
want any trouble can you see him doing
that here again this is a reference to
our theme of the gods
fearing the dark returning to Medea he's
a descendant of arch dragons was raised
by the gods and owing to his immortality
was given a duty to eternally battle the
dark a duty that he would never forget
even after the gods perish even his full
name attests to his duty it's dark
eternity
he's one who battles with and even
consumes the dark the eater part of his
name probably helped lead to his
corruption as consuming the dark without
being affected by it would seem an
impossible task Medea was used by the
gods to help fight the fear of the dark
he was cursed from the beginning and
doomed to fall as the brute force of a
dragon is not something that could ever
hope to conquer the deep unrelenting tug
of darkness this next progression in the
city will have shiro turn against you
entering phooey indoors church makes it
clear that your intentions are not to
defend the leonore's slumber as shiro
would have thought judicata Argo the
seeming leader of the Jew Decatur's I
mentioned before warns you Tilly and if
you do not see someone's half light or
any other sphere of the church to come
stop you upon arrival he mentions how
you must leave in keeping with the Kings
decree this means that when placed the
decree that none were allowed to come
wake Fillion or the daughter we have to
wonder what the importance of filial or
slumber is it's so many in the ring city
would go to such lengths to protect it
and even Gwyn would decree it to be
protected but as we our Dark Souls
players we ignore all of this
and kill our way forward past the fight
up the elevator and a couple steps
resides princess Lillian or in her sleep
holding in a decrepit egg waking her
sends us into a wasteland of ash
one description I heard of it was the
ashen weight and that's something that I
really think captures the idea of this
environment the rain city is destroyed
and buried I guess we can see why no one
wanted us to wake the princess up making
our way through the wasteland we find a
pygmy Lord
dragging himself to philia Nora's room
begging for help the complexity of the
implications in this area is absolutely
astounding off in the distance we can
see the ruins of lothric and anor londo
and the wasteland extends everywhere one
could even posit that all the other
kingdoms we know of dragging like astora
catarina have suffered the same fate it
does bring up many questions though
obviously time is convoluted throughout
the game so did we just jump forward in
time or as feeling north sleep only
casting an illusion on the ring city
like Gwendolyn did in Dark Souls 1 at
the moment I unfortunately do not have
any great answers or further
explanations of this area at least in
this video we can discuss it more in a
later video but at any rate everything's
pretty messed up so here we are at the
final boss of the dark souls franchise
slave night Gale he's consumed the dark
soul of the pygmy Lords and now wants
yours he's been completely corrupted by
the darkness Gale wasn't anything
special before he was a slave knight
ever dedicated to serving his master the
painter he besieged your help in the
painted world and then took it upon
himself to find the painter the pigment
she needed taking on a universe of
terrors and monsters he knew she wasn't
like God or a lord or a king or any of
that he was just a slate and when he
reached his destination he was met with
a surprise for when Gale came upon the
pygmy Lords he discovered that their
blood and long ago dried and so he
consumed the dark soul Gale wanted to
use the blood of the Dark Soul as
pigment for his lady
however the pygmy Lords could no longer
provide that someone needed to convert
the dark soul into blood that could be
used as pigment so he did what he had to
do
and consume the Dark Soul probably
knowing that he wouldn't be able to
control it and that someone would have
to come stop it maybe before he lost his
mind he even knew that you would be the
one to stop him he sacrificed making the
decision he knew had to be made the
painter needed the blood of the Dark
Soul he provided it Dale was like us
nothing special just a determined person
where the drive to refrain from becoming
Hollow and to carry out his task ending
the series with such a similar and
familiarly tragic character was a very
welcomed experience for me as I said you
can give the painter the blood of the
Dark Soul once you overcome Gail she's
overjoyed ensure that she will paint a
goodly world one that she hopes can be a
peaceful home for Gail I know Gail will
be a peace with this ending and so on my
thanks to all of you for watching advice
to also thank the Dark Souls community
on reddit and on discord for offering
tons of great ideas and helping me form
my own thoughts on what happened
throughout this dlc also with
corrections whenever I got something
wrong a lot of what is in this video
kane in part or in full from ideas and
discussions i saw and had in these
places so i definitely don't take credit
for coming up with everything in this
video i do hope you enjoyed and stick
around because i do plan to delve deeper
and really look at the lore of things
like gayle m'dear and the like there's a
ton more to talk about with laughs with
Gayle with the final area - and ways to
one thing to note that the ashen wastes
appear in the intro cinematic and on the
cover of the game which is which is mind
blowing so I do want to look at all of
that in more debt this video wasn't too
in-depth it was more a broad picture I
had to quickly go over a lot of content
I talked about because I wanted to try
and touch on everything super-important
to the core lore in this DLC thanks
again and always remember the gods
caused so much trouble so much pain and
curse and suffering because they were
afraid of the dark
he's not everyone
[Music]